et c'est emmanuel macron qui est réélu
président de la république
si le président demeure le même si le
duel du deuxième tour et est annoncé
cette campagne fut sans précédent sur
fond d'abstention record
entre guerre en ukraine crise sanitaire
les fatigues du politique la campagne a
eu du mal à s'imposer
et la fonte en sort plus fracturées que
jamais
aucun candidat ne plaide donc je me pose
la question est-ce que je vais voter
j'ai toujours été votée tout s'ils
parlent d'eux mêmes le même trou si je
parle pas de en fait il parle pas de
problème le vrai problème de la
population je suis très très inquiet
d'un deuxième tour entre mâcon et le pen
récit d'une drôle de campagne à travers
le combat de quatre députés ultra
impliqués
marie-christine verdier jouclas elle se
démène pour faire réélire son président
ma journée ce dame à l'autre bout du
tableau n'est pas ce genre de journal
damien abad à l'époque président du
groupe l air à l'assemblée nationale il
assiste au naufrage de sa candidate et
s'interroge sur son propre avenir
je pense que l'inquiétude ne serait pas
été mieux compte après moi j'ai su
bertrand poussé
matile de panneaux députés en soumises
des quartiers populaires à la tête du
groupe elle ya cru jusqu'à l'annoncé des
résultats du premier tour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sébastien chenu porte parole de marine
le pen député du nord qui fait tout pour
briser le plafond de verre de la
candidate d'extrême droite
est en marche et n'ont pas peur
voyage en france sur les routes d'une
campagne qui a ouvert la voie à une
totale recomposition politique
[Musique]
vittel pour la journée mondiale de l'eau
nous sommes à trois semaines du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle
des militants pour la planète dénoncent
l'entreprise nestlé qui puise dans les
nappes phréatiques pour sa marque vite
elle
mathilde de panneaux a voulu en être
l'eau c'est son dossier
elle capitalise sur le travail des
députés est la fille durant cinq ans
et rappelle ainsi que le programme de
jean luc mélenchon est rouge mais aussi
vers
l'inattendu comme ministre ce qui nous
va
j'avais mené notamment de la commission
denquête que je présidais sur la
question de l'eau elle souhaite montrer
que l'entourage du candidat mélenchon
travail les dossiers vous savez que
depuis 2020 on peut spéculer sur l'eau
en bourse en californie par les deux
fonds pour dire qu'il y à une
alternative à emmanuel macron
l'idée d'aujourd'hui c'est pas deux de
faire un peu de la politicaille c'est
vraiment de donner du soutien c'est du
tla et de dire que tout ça est issu de
choix politiques qu'on pourrait faire
tout autrement dans nos pays sur cet
électorat qui est du dérèglement du
climat
sont candidats à marquer des points ce
jour là il est à 14% d'intentions de
vote dans les sondages mon troisième
position quand yannick jadot taisne à 5%
l'eau est un bien commun l'air est un
bien commun les sols sont des biens
communs à nous de les protéger et jean
luc mélenchon est le candidat qui pourra
nous aider a justement à protéger nos
ressources notamment les ressources en
eau ne serait pas élu mais au moins
qu'ils aillent au delà parce que moi il
y aura un départ en ivoire de fond sur
les conceptions que les gens peut on pas
ce qu'on fait simple one qui a été
construit en groupes séparés c'est pas
jean-luc où il veut tout seul une équipe
michel est une retraitée engagé mais de
là à voter jean luc mélenchon sinon
puis c'est trop excessif
l'abstention promet d'être forte les
indécis nombreux
faire campagne c'est aller chercher les
dégoûtés de la politique
le second tour ne paraît pas si
inaccessible
vous savez quand vous avez 10 millions
personnes sous le seuil de pauvreté 8
millions de personnes qui ont besoin de
l'aide alimentaire que vous avez 12
millions de personnes qui ont froid chez
elle
il ya une majorité social du pays qui a
quand même envie de rentrer avec ce
système là et alors qu'est ce qu'est ce
qui manque bon bah de briser ce petit
truc de résignation de toute façon rien
ne changera jamais mais en fait oui tout
peut changer avec cette élection
présidentielle voilà c'est ça qu'on leur
dit aux gens
hachez désolé mais j'ai froid la députée
ne ménage pas ses efforts
dans quelques jours elle sera aux
antilles pour convaincre les électeurs
ultramarins
[Musique]
23 mars 2022 la campagne est sur pause
le temps d'une journée
les députés sont obligés de revenir à
paris le président ukrainien valeur
adressé un message pour savoir s'adapter
à la situation c'est un moment de la
guerre percute la campagne
la guerre donne de la gravité à
l'élection présidentielle
les français sont inquiets et une
inquiétude sur les conséquences de cette
guerre pour eux sur leur pouvoir d'achat
on le voit avec le prix à la pompe des
carburants notamment qui a des
conséquences aussi géopolitique monsieur
le président de l'ukraine vous avez la
parole
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
les élus de paris le peuple français je
voudrais poser une question comment
arrêter cette guerre
face à l'impuissance des pays
occidentaux
les français sont davantage sidéré par
les images de guerre
qu'intéressé par l'élection
présidentielle on doit faire campagne
malgré tout parce qu'on a un projet
présidentiel a présenté pour les cinq
ans à venir et il faut qu'on puisse
parler aux françaises et aux français de
ce qu'on veut leur proposer et en même
temps faut qu'on reste sobre et qu'on
soit dans l'écouteur parce qu'ils sont
quand même inquiet de la situation
inquiète de la situation
ainsi et l'entourage de valérie pécresse
qui sur la dernière ligne droite
cumulent les handicaps
comment vous allez ce soir et comment
vous aborder ces quinze derniers jours
de campagne en ayant le qu'ovide écouter
aujourd'hui tout va à peu près bien sauf
que je vous je m'entends en écho dans
mon oreille donc c'est très très
compliqué la candidate des républicains
plonge de jour en jour dans les sondages
sur le terrain à cet instant de
l'histoire damien abad se démène pour
convaincre les électeurs de droite dos
restés fidèles au parti
ce jour-là il sillonne sa
circonscription la quatrième de l'ain si
c'est plus à droite
de conviction
ça joue entre entre nous le ten aisément
mais le travail de conviction s'avère
ardue
le soir au salon des vins d'oyonnax
sympathisants et militants de droite n'y
croit plus beaucoup font même des
allusions bien appuyé lui un des barons
dlr pourrait rejoindre la république en
marche après la présidentielle
marie chouinard d'habitants soit la
gauche la rue on va chercher un chargeur
karine rappel
c'est la gauche qui paye son coude
compatible sortes d'abus sexuels
cependant pris soin dont la dernière
le parti est pétrifié le peuple de
droite déboussolée par une campagne qui
prend des allures de fiasco comment ça
se fait avec du bois
des pratiques a pas de campagne
pas de débat pas est à un moment tu vois
où voilà quoi je pense c'est sympa sans
doute donc moi on est d'accord mais mais
après le reste voilà bah écoute et se
bat et là franchement c'est une bosseuse
survenir enlever ça
bon allez même les encouragions rester
l'air
les militants s'interroge beaucoup sur
le second tour quitte à refaire le match
des primaires
j'utilise autres engagés au deuxième
tour on suit ton plein dans un
macron alors la région va bien
j'aimerais bien voter deux fois le même
candidate j'aimerais bien voter deux
fois fait grâce c'est à dire que la
deuxième fois que tu toi parti avec ma
crotoy là on est le problème c'est que
moi je pense que c'est la seule qui peut
battre maxime
castillo qui ne serait pas été mieux la
côte après moi j'ai sauté bertrand
poussins es ce que vous avez réussi
encore à
ça je suis pas sûr mais par contre ce
que je pense qu'il votera pourront les
châtiments d'aller voter alors à
le diable
à quinze jours du premier tour damien
abad préfère face caméra pratiquer la
langue de bois
apparel de jenson qui hésite elle dans
votre électorat vous passez à la wii
mais c'est plutôt bon signe ça veut dire
qu'il y en a beaucoup au sic et voiliers
qui sont pas comptabilisés dans les
sondages et qui disent finalement d'un
moment votre à pécresse parce qu'on est
de la famille d'avoir week-end parce
qu'on veut un gouvernement de droite
parce qu'on veut une prison de droit
comme quand on voit que c'est possible
il faut expliquer il fera la pédagogie
je prends du temps mais moi je pense que
rien est impossible
un pécresse ouais bah ouais
d'accord
[Musique]
va gagner
depuis des semaines marine le pen mène
une campagne presque apaisé sans heurts
ni vociférations eric zemmour a failli
la faire vaciller mais il se révèle
davantage comme est que tempêtes
et un mantra pour sébastien chenu le
porte parole de la campagne marine le
pen a la stature d'une femme d'état
d'autres avant d'entrer dans le détail
une phrase qui a attiré notre attention
ce matin c'est dans le journal du
dimanche marine le pen dit si je suis
battu a priori je ne me représenterai
pas est ce que c'est la dernière chance
de la dynastie mme le pen fn et rennes
vous savez je crois que marine le pen
aujourd'hui elle est prête et d'ailleurs
il ya quelque chose de très important
parce qu'ils tombent aux prendre en
considération sec et on le voit les
semaines passant si le peuple vote alors
le peuple va gagner et si les français
vont voter si le peuple français va
voter marine le pen va être président de
la république ses six aînés brian le
peuple a perdu elle elle considère
qu'aujourd'hui il est possible aussi de
perdre mais je crois qu'en réalité elle
n'a jamais été aussi proche de la
victoire elle n'a jamais été aussi prêt
à gouverner
pendant ce temps là les députés de la
majorité présidentielle renoue avec les
vieilles habitudes
albi dont le tarn marie-christine
verdier jouclas privilégie la proximité
la méthode des marcheurs le porte à
porte à l'opposé de son candidat un
président qui se tient hors de portée
d'engueulades selon l'expression
consacrée au jour une oisellerie je suis
marie-christine vers 10hoo classe sur la
députée du tarn que la chose avait à 19
ans d'accord on vous allez voter
peut-être pour la première fois ce que
vous savez quand est-ce qu'on vote quand
est-ce que c'est le premier tour un non
celle en deux semaines ah d'accord il ya
d'autres problèmes qui sont je trouve
majeure en ce moment et du coup on n'a
pas vraiment envie de penser politique
on a envie de penser ce qu'on peut le
faire par rapport à la guerre
merci beaucoup un seul mot d'ordre ne
pas céder à l'excès de confiance
même si emmanuel macron est donné favori
par les sondages
tous les matins quand je me lève c'est
de dire que rien n'est fait le soir
quand je me couche c'est de dire que
rien n'est fait et donc être sur le
terrain être mobilisés être à l'écouté
si vous comprendre aussi pourquoi et
convaincre d'aller voter ce qui est
certain c'est qu'il faut toujours
rappeler que marine le pen marine le pen
pardon c'est l'extrême droite
défendre un candidat a mobilisé sur la
scène européenne et mondiale
bonjour monsieur
c'est un atout majeur de crédibilité je
reconnais que emmanuel macron
sur le plan
international sur peau représentent bien
la france
comme ça on pourrait regarder ce qu'on
propose pour les cinq années à venir y
compris pour les seniors
bonjour madame mais très vite les vieux
dossiers reçus augis élus sur la
circonscription de habitait dans le
quartier oui je ne vais pas voter pour
monsieur macro d'accord il ya des
mesures par exemple les attentes il a
supprimé les 5 euros à l'apl ça c'était
au tout début au tout début la loire non
mais ça c'était quelque chose qui
m'avait choqué vous hésitez à voter pour
qui sans les verts
vous est ce que pour ça je pense qu'il a
fait pincer on a hélas il faut mettre le
turbo maintenant alors parce que parce
que on va dans le mur et
je mets bien sûr on n'est pas allé assez
loin et il faut aller plus loin et je me
permet quand même de vous donner le
projet vous le lirez quand même vous
regarderez ce qu'on peut faire sur les
origines puisque ces sommes alors ne me
fait pas plaisir si vous devez pas le
lire je le regarde merci madame enfin
harrouard après cinq ans d'exercice du
pouvoir
pas toujours facile de défendre le en
même temps à dix jours du premier tour
mathilde de panneaux intensifie encore
le rythme de sa campagne et ce jour là
le temps ne l'aide pas bonjour alex on
prévient elle le 10 avril
bonjour élections peuvent lancer la
semaine prochaine si vous avez envie de
se baigner ce soir on fait un meeting à
ivry
voilà moi je suis député moi je suis
débuté avec jean luc mélenchon jabeur
voilà elle va superbe si vous avez envie
on va parler du programme où les du jeu
luc turgeon beau jeu suivant il va y
arriver on va y arriver
[Musique]
son objectif est clairement de mobiliser
les abstentionnistes des quartiers
populaires marvin 25 ans pas se laisser
convaincre voilà si vous avez le temps
vous êtes bienvenu
pour qui vous allez voter monsieur moi
oui je vois que pour mélenchon n'y a que
lui sinon ils nous proposent que la
droite ait toujours voté ou des fois
vous n'y allez pas se venger elle est
pas parce que droite ou gauche pour moi
c'est la même chose ils ont un estomac
la place du coeur
du clergé mais on va passer
quand les gens sont en colère ou que
voilà il ya des choses qui
killer remue les tripes du coup après
effectivement c'est des punchline que
vous pourriez réutiliser pratiquement
toutes prêtes à l'assemblée nationale à
quelques encablures des tractages pour
les candidats pc et ps aux oubliettes
dans les sondages il a percuté leur nom
on dit plutôt vote efficace c'est sûr
qu'il y aille au premier tour de cette
élection présidentielle un vote efficace
qui permet à la fois d'éliminer
l'extrême droite du premier tour et
d'avoir un autre débat que de nouveaux
un macaron le pen avec les débats rend
ce qu'on connaît sur la question
migratoire
l'après midi même à ivry-sur-seine comme
trois fois par semaine mathilde de
panneaux se met en place pour un meeting
mais avant cela elle n'oublie pas ce qui
a fait la force des insoumis dans cette
campagne
une vidéo pour facebook twitter et les
autres
meetings pour soutenir la candidature de
jean-luc mélenchon et la candidature de
l'union populaire
venez nombreux et nombreuses on vous y
attend au plaisir de vous y voir à 70
ans jean luc mélenchon et le candidat
aux deux millions d'abonnés sur tik tok
le réseau des jeunes
c'est des moyens de communication pour
nous qui sont assez fabuleux parce que
quand vous avez une vidéo comme on en
fait régulièrement ou vous avez un
million de millions voire 3 millions de
vues c'est faut imaginer l'équivalent en
traque de ce que ça veut dire donc pour
nous c'est des moyens de communication
extrêmement puissant
sur la dernière ligne droite
mathilde de panneaux et les autres
députés et les filles remplissent 35 par
semaine
nous sommes une force populaire
incomparable dans le pays aucune autre
bord politique ne peut s'en sont
candidats réunir autant de gens
[Applaudissements]
ce sont les politiques de l'histoire
rien les fuites avance vous êtes ses
murs et directoire
ambiance diamétralement opposées du côté
des macros nice
le président-candidat s'offre la plus
grande salle d'europe avec 30000 places
occupées pour son sol meeting d'avant
premier tour
[Musique]
pour marie-christine verdi jouclas c'est
une parenthèse enchantée dans une
campagne un peu tristoune
une façon de revivifier l'esprit des
débuts marie-christine verdier jouclas
est issu du monde de l'entreprise et a
commencé la politique en 2017
le mouvement en marche c'est emmanuel
macron et pour moi c'est toujours
emmanuel matt rand et c'est vrai que
c'est lui que j'ai suivi parce qu'il a
pris des engagements que j'ai cru en lui
j'ai cru en son programme mais cinq ans
on appris aujourd'hui mais je suis
toujours à la même conviction et et ça
lui je ne sais pas ce que ça pourrait
être en tout cas
[Applaudissements]
il arrive
[Musique]
en superstar
pour le plus grand plaisir de la députée
le président-candidat renoue avec le et
de droite et de gauche je crois allant
même temps
du jacobinisme et du giron 10 mhz on
doit pouvoir y arriver
alors j'assume oui de vous dire qu'il
faudra travailler plus et d'abord
travailler plus longtemps parce que nous
vivons plus vieux la député reçoit aussi
le message d'un président grave
l'extrême droite seraient aux portes du
pouvoir
regarder du break site attendent
élections ce qui paraissait improbable
et qui est a pu advenir alors je vous le
dis avec beaucoup de force ce soir je
veux la mobilisation générale
la volontaire à l'action
du côté du rassemblement national
justement on occupe le terrain là où
sont les classes populaires dans les
vide greniers
un dimanche ensoleillé dans le nord
marine
sébastien chenu député du coin est
connue de tous
ça va marcher
inquiétez pas
on y va
ici dans cette france des oubliés déjà
en 2017 on a voté à 40 % pour le fn au
premier tour le
fn devenu rn promettent encore de
progrès si ici les gens ont été les
premiers impactés par les décisions
politiques qui ont été prises depuis 40
ans allez ici on va fermer une usine or
ici on a fermé les mines les gens ont
subi la mondialisation en premier et
bien comme ils ont subi en premier ont
réagi en premier
en battant la campagne sur le pouvoir
d'achat depuis six mois en gommant sa
radicalité sur l'immigration l'équipe
lepéniste a visé juste
je vais là-bas la commande
d'environ 1% et la france à ses
relations il est d'accord on est
peut-être tchèque pour former aller là
où les autres ne vont pas comme marina
bay 6 à bouchain pour cantalien dans
d'autres villes cela viendra kenya
minutes et une politique filières dans
lesquelles les gens ne voient jamais
comme ça le passé c'est toujours dans
les grandes métropoles les
applaudissements la cuillère avec une
ronde max hild oublie toute une partie
de la vente et donc qu'une partie des
français quand les députés du
rassemblement national privilégie une
campagne à l'ancienne
celles et ceux de l'affront 100 soumises
paris sur la technologie
super
tous meetings en attend très nombreux et
nombreuses pauses et l'avoir fait en
éliminant son procès rond point avec
sanofi des
effets gars entier
[Musique]
pour son dernier meeting avant le
premier tour entouré de mathilde de
panneaux et d'autres députés jean luc
mélenchon et ces hologrammes rassemble
vingt mille personnes
par tout on fonce
[Applaudissements]
avant la fin de la campagne électorale
la france qui se cherche
le peuple qui tâtonne
regarde vers nous
et se dit
voilà la france
voilà celle que nous voulons
[Applaudissements]
à trois jours du premier tour les
républicains eux sonne le glas d'une
campagne ratée
on va on va s'en sortir
a lyon ce soir là règne une atmosphère
de désolation
damien abad jouent les cassandre
ses projections que le placer devant mc
- dimanche
par l'independent et vote utile comment
ça va faire fidèle sarkozyste brice
hortefeux semble abattu
[Applaudissements]
ça
commence mais bon
c'est bien
timide c'est bien
tout le monde craint pour l'avenir du
parti les personnalités lr vont-elles
appelé à voter emmanuel macron et au
front républicain hal annonce des
résultats du premier tour tels et déjà
la question
discussions entre damien abad et un
membre dlr la fille de l erp et voir
mais ni front républicain dans dimanche
soir j'attends camon
tous les électeurs je me donnerai aucune
envie
n'est ce pas
[Applaudissements]
dernier mot de la candidate et petit
message personnel dans une campagne
annonciatrice d'un cataclysme
je voudrais dire à damien abad à damien
abad qu'il a été un formidable président
de groupe à l'assemblée nationale cette
campagne qui devait être celle des
débauchages n'a pas eu lieu et la
gamelle macro nien est resté assez peu
rempli alors je le dis merci damien
bravo
quelques semaines plus tard damien abad
en personne sera la principale prise de
guerre d' emmanuel macron aux
républicains
nommé ministre du gouvernement bornes le
parlementaire de 42 ans se mettra en
congé du parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à trois jours du premier tour perpignan
la ville dirigée par louis aliot devient
la capitale du rassemblement national
plus de 3000 personnes la tombe
[Musique]
cette fois ci je suis persuadé qu'elle
va gagner
parce que je fasse je le sens contraire
nous les militants en hauts de garonne
quand on va sur les marchés à la
rencontre des français
là on se rend compte que vraiment cette
fois ci c'est la bonne on est bien
accueilli surtout sur les marchés tout
ça les gens parler tout à ses plus comme
avant rats non le pen surtout pas le pen
non la sauvage
[Musique]
sébastien chenu et particulièrement
serein
je pense que marine le pen est prête et
que les gens le sentent parce que de
l'autre côté noël macron il a un bilan
et que les gens le ressentent dans un
pays qui a été beaucoup abîmé beaucoup
brutalisé et qui aspire à être unis à
être réunies
même ambiance de calme et de sérénité
dont la loge de la candidate à quelques
minutes de son entrée en scène du
français ont pris conscience qu'on ne
peut pas se permettre cinq années de
plus des manuels macro qu'est ce qui a
changé entre 2017 et aujourd'hui en 2022
bah tout a changé tout a changé le pays
d'ailleurs lui-même a changé pas en
mieux hélas mais je pense qu'à une un
sentiment d'urgence
pour les militants le programme du r n
est perçu comme n'étant plus d'extrême
droite marine le pen se veut la
protectrice des classes populaires
[Applaudissements]
prochain
j'ose le dire et je l'assumerai
question
et qu'elles étaient toutes en achat de
qualité de vie le travail l'école
recharge encore au mieux rire dans le
voilà
et le message social irradiées au delà
des sympathisants et rennes marine le
pen a réussi son comble m au coeur de la
campagne la question du pouvoir d'achat
pour les classes populaires mais aussi
pour les classes moyennes qui craignent
le déclassement
l'avant veille du premier tour
marie-christine verdier jouclas veut
raviver l'électorat de gauche d'emmanuel
macron
direction carmaux la terre de jaurès
tout un symbole
ici les gens n'hésitent pas à lui dire
ce qu'il pense du bilan du quinquennat
[Musique]
pour moi c'est pas du tout assez social
alors dites moi pourquoi ça m'intéresse
vraiment parce que voyez on a supprimé
la taxe d'habitation
on a baissé les impôts des deux
premières tranches moi j'entends quand
vous dites qu'on n'est pas seul mais
alors si le roi ne pas en temps
j'entends des tas de gens qui vivent
autour de moi oui et qui disent on
entend parler dead on les perçoit port
on a
on a toujours des impôts importants on
vit difficilement ça ne s'améliore pas
le débat s'en veut ni même parfois sur
la tentation du vote le pen
pour moi c'est un mode d'expression au
pouvoir si on sort de la démocratie
vous ne faites pas confiance aux
français ne sont pas capables eux mêmes
de choisir ce qu'ils ont mais quand on a
des candidats qui servent
systématiquement sur les peurs quand on
brandit le drapeau les immigrés ils sont
là ils vous prennent votre travail ils
prennent toutes les aides ils sont en
train de mettre aa c'est notre pays vous
croyez que ça c'est un discours qu'on
peut accepter parce que les jeunes sont
ainsi capables ils sont assez adultes
pour savoir si moi ce jeu mais dans la
capitale soit dit et je suis persuadé
mais tout le respect que je vous dois je
suis persuadé que les jeunes il faut
arrêtez arrêtez de les pendre police en
face au mur à ya pas de soucis aux vélos
d'image je vous souhaite beaucoup de
place et que vous allez voter voilà ça
c'est vrai ça c'est une vérité par
contre voici mes joueurs aujourd'hui
deux jours plus tard les deux premiers
candidats annoncés par les sondages
seront bien en tête en revanche tous les
autres parties connaissent d'incroyables
surprises
il est 20 heures voici le résultat du
premier tour en tête ce soir emmanuel
macron devant marine le pen face à face
attendu
mais anne hidalgo pour le ps affiche à
peine plus que lutte ouvrière et valérie
pécresse n'atteint pas finalement la
barre des 5% un énorme fiasco pour les
partis dits de gouvernement qui se sont
partagé le pouvoir tout au long de la 5e
république
jean luc mélenchon se hisse en troisième
position ces 7 millions 700 mille
électeurs vont bientôt être considérés
comme des faiseurs de roi
[Musique]
le soir du premier tour tout le monde
attend les consignes de vote du vétéran
de la présidentielle
visiblement bouleversé
mathilde de panneaux sait que la
qualification pourrait les filles a été
manquée à 400 mille voix près seulement
des nôtres pas de l'aide va le voir
madame le pen
il ne faut pas donner une seule voix
madame le pen et de lancer un mot
d'ordre qui va faire son chemin
le troisième tour les législatives
nous avons devant nous d'autres aux
élections nous tiendrons à chaque étape
notre rang
en attendant les prochaines élections
plus personne n'utilise l'expression de
front républicain la fameuse formule du
ni-ni elle aussi n'est plus d'actualité
chez les as l'air on dit peu ou prou la
même chose le lendemain du vote c'est le
branle bas de combat
le patron christian jacob s'évertue à
expliquer une ligne un peu flou une
ligne qui a surtout l'avantagé de
ménager la chèvre et le chou en
aucune voix ne se portera jamais sur
marine le pen simplement certains
choisiront de voter blanc et d'autres
choisiront un bulletin un bulletin macro
c'est une réalité on va pas la cacher
damien abad lui se veut plus explicite
on le dit plus que jamais ma trop
compact et bien hier soir voilà je
voterai emmanuel macron je ne peux pas
un signe égal entre entre l'extrême
droite et le candidat républicain et
c'est ce que je vais défendre ce matin
merci non mais on n'est pas là dedans
sur le sujet aujourd'hui c'est déjà
l'élection présidentielle deuxième tour
mais à ce stade de l'histoire les
législatives on est déjà tous les
esprits
du côté du r'n les résultats du premier
tour sont plein de promesses sébastien
chenu dès le lundi matin enchaîne les
plateaux télé avec une analyse des
reports de voix qui augurerait d'une
victoire de sa candidate
[Musique]
pour la première fois on a des réserves
pour la première fois ces malades mâcon
qui doit aller en chercher les
quatre points quand même entre les deux
visible dans les paquets on est bon mais
là ce niveau là non plus oui on est on
est plutôt confiant quoi qui a aucun
électeur de jean luc mélenchon de fabien
roussel voire même daigner jadot qui est
prêt à sauver la tête d' emmanuel macron
en se disant je verrai élire un
président de la brutalité le président
des gilets jaunes qui les a et bornier
le président de la retraite à 65 ans
il va dérouler son discours
il va répéter à l'envié que le président
de la république ne peut pas se
métamorphoser subitement en candidat de
gauche qu'il a appauvri les plus pauvres
en somme faire des manuels macron
l'homme du passif
on vous l a confirmé des lits d'hôpitaux
on vous avait laissé des retraités avec
8 euros par jour pour subsister on vous
avait une part est indexé mais le
traître
deuxième objectif préparer le débat et
ne pas réitérer la prestation déplorable
de marine le pen face à emmanuel macron
en 2017
on va voir comment s'organise
aura des sparring partners comme promis
en tout le cas des partenaires de débats
on verra j'ai quoi comment le fait
important je pense que c'est le fonds le
fonds le fonds vous aviez joué emmanuel
macron en 2017 face à l jeu
éditions
avant le départ la candidate du r n
oubliera pas de se mettre au vert pour
être reposé le jour j
se mettre au vert une obligation pour la
députée macro nist testée positive au co
vide marie-christine verdier jouclas
doit s'isoler interrompre sa campagne
certaine que quand elle pourra sortir
elle parviendra à convertir des
électeurs mélenchonistes de voter macron
ici dans son fief
à rabat 16 dans la commune j'habite
mélange en a fait plus de 33% devoir
donc c'était pareil en 2017 mais pas
avec un écart aussi important les 33 %
il ya dedans des gens à qui
effectivement on pourra aller s'adresser
et leur prouver que notre projet est un
projet social est aussi un projet de
gauche
le jour même emmanuel macron va au
contact cibler les classes populaires
une visite donnant dans le nord et très
vite on largue
moi j'ai mon ami je n'ai pas coutume
j'ai mon ami j'aimerais bien vous
n'aurez pas voir que cbc du temps vous
avez dit emballé la pompe à essence vous
y allez vous même ou pas du marché vous
gagnez combien par mois reste alors à
tandja le niveau mon mari ouvrier moi je
suis à huit heures par semaine attendez
je finis aussi et donc ça devient
compliqué un échange médiatisé qui
tranche avec la première partie de la
campagne
sur le terrain justement la bataille se
durcit pour marine le pen ce jour là
dans le vaucluse un département où elle
est arrivée largement en tête au premier
tour et pourtant
très vite des manifestations la renvoie
à ses racines d'extrême droite
des habitants conteste un point de son
programme l'interdiction du voile dans
tout l'espace public
un uniforme
je cherche à imposer situerait à mesure
du tort des gens qui ont une vision
radicale de banal c'est ce qu'on a
vraiment c'est pas très malin alors
d'accord avec vous
la stratégie de dédiabolisation menée
par le parti depuis des années semble ne
pas fonctionner sur tous les français
le soir même à avignon un nouveau
meeting permettent de rassembler les
siens
sébastien chenu est évidemment au rendez
vous
quatre mille personnes sont venues
acclamer leurs combattants
c'est la mobilisation était connu ses
premiers meetings pas de tour sa
première grande si de parole de marine
le pen dont deux des stores et des
enfants
petit aparté avec caroline parmentier ça
va car la conseillère presse de marine
le pen une pièce maîtresse de la
campagne allez
les libéraux de 5 à 10 minutes ça peu
près ne l'a vu pour la voix du nord j'ai
vu pour la voix du nord le seul problème
c'est que je ne sais pas
ce soir là sébastien chenu retrouve
d'autres élus comme emmanuel blé riz
député du pas-de-calais
vraiment intéressant voilà on est hyper
motivé là pour la campagne
au fil de la campagne sébastien chenu
est devenu populaire
[Musique]
noël chaleureux et volubile
il sait y faire un petit mot pour chacun
et un sourire pour tous
[Musique]
moi je l'aimé bien parce qu'il a une
prestance il sera pas relayée
il est proche du peuple
comme à chaque fois marine le pen veut
insister sur le dégage isme
personnes modestes personnes des classes
moyennes même des classes aisées qui
subissent et ce pouvoir centré autour
d'un homme un homme seul
[Applaudissements]
bain de foule pour marine le pen on veut
la touche et la photographier lui parler
incarnation d'un espoir populaire
ironie de l'histoire quelques instants
plus tard certains militants rentrer
chez eux ont du sma kron
le président justement il cherche lui à
rosir son discours pour attirer les
électeurs de gauche mais aussi à lever
redire marie-christine verdier jouclas
défend bec et ongles le bilan écolo de
la majorité selon elle l'arrêt des
centrales à charbon ou du plastique à
usage unique était une preuve
d'engagement pour la planète
le discours de marseille non serait que
la suite logique
ce 16 avril la le candidat macron pas
son ovaire foncier
[Musique]
la politique que je mènerai dans les
cinq ans à venir sera donc écologique ou
ne sera pas
et donc
pour placer l'écologie au coeur du
nouveau paradigme politique mon prochain
premier ministre
sera directement chargé de la
planification écologique grave
le fait qu'on dise qu'on doit aller
beaucoup plus loin sur des enjeux
importants que l'écologie fait partie de
ces enjeux importants mais pourquoi on
dirait que c'est un sincère c'est
répondre à une attente c'est écouter
aussi et c'est pas juste draguer les
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon et
yannick jadot c'est leur apporter l'idée
clair qu'on veut aller dans le même sens
de toute façon et que d'un autre
programme il y avait déjà le goji ce
soir là c'est le débat un moment qu'elle
va partager comme il y a cinq ans avec
des militants en marche
dans la même salle d'ailleurs qu'en 2017
au début de son engagement politique
la députée devient plus que jamais
supporters
il faut dire que ce jour là le candidat
macron a enfilé les gants de boxe pour
le plus grand plaisir de la députée vous
ne parlez pas à d'autres dirigeants aux
banquiers comparer
c'est aussi ce qui fait que le prévenu
qu'on ne pouvait pas défendre
correctement sur ce sujet les intérêts
de la france parce que vos intérêts sont
liés à des gens proches des couloirs
qu'il faut aider les très petites
entreprises en leur accordant des
baisses d'officialité par grands groupes
japon comme vous l'avez c'est ce qu'on a
fait pas là c'est un garçon parler de
baisse d'impôts vous pensez toujours au
lait c'est pas vrai c'est pareil les
français seront prioritairement
bénéficiaires de lâcher le championnat
mx1 et les chefs d'entreprises pourront
donner une priorité aux français dans
les embauches cinétique de gauche on
l'appelle de avec sky est de dire aux
régimes arabes seraient
ces réactions sont relayés par son armée
de tweets hausse
c'est une façon de réagir le montrer à
la fois notre soutien pour le candidat
emmanuel macron mais aussi de d'appuyer
là où ça fait un peu mal c'est à dire de
montrer excusez moi mais l'incompétence
de la candidate marine le pen
sur cauet rennes on n'aura pas les mêmes
éléments de langage
le lendemain sébastien chenu recommence
sa tournée des plateaux télé pour
commenter le débat sur le terrain c'est
son acolyte député emmanuel blé riz qui
relaie cette parole
[Musique]
d'accord super vous avez le trac la
présidentielle marine le pen oui j'ai vu
le des bayards oui mais ils étaient 13
euros alors vous voyez qui lui a coupé
la parole est une fois c'est pas honnête
on est vraiment j'ai croisé des dizaines
de personnes sur le marché tourne sort
ce harry se profile un de leurs
arrogants ne le regarde même pas drôle
un régime c'est du mépris ça c'est lié
mépris mais en fait s'il a agi là
pendant trois heures comme il ajoute que
peuvent penser pendant cinq ans
ici 39 % des électeurs ont voté marine
le pen au premier tour 15% seulement
emmanuel macron dans les alliés il se
fait surprendre par des propos pourtant
ils préféreraient ne plus voir avait
chez
eux pour qu'ils votent on pourquoi pas
pour marine le pen
[Rires]
avait vu des bailleurs j'aurais pensé
j'ai pensé que l'on vit c'est un petit
morveux ici n'y avait quand même bon
snobisme accord dans peu de temps simple
et mouloud
disons que l'os est le prénom le prénom
sont pas non mais qui ait bien compris
ce que j'ai voulu dire les prénoms sont
pas son premier rôle important s'ils
vivent sous le même drapeau tous
ensemble voilà c'est de s'entendre et de
vivre côte-à-côte plutôt que face à face
les débats a aussi laissé des traces
monsieur à prague pour la présidentielle
marine le pen à gm en venant vous
comporter avec les a écoutés mais déjà
ça et en plus vous lui dont il n'y a pas
de complot monsieur hulot qui
accueillit poutine en france et bâle est
prête pour
le plus sûr pour essaimer presque encore
les meetings le dernier de la campagne
pour marine le pen se tient arras
à l'intérieur comme à son habitude
sébastien chenu se prête au jeu des
selles fille
[Musique]
le pas de calais à ghislaine exactement
si peur de lui le mont rim salle de voir
ça manque de marqueur ballon d'or il ya
du monde
à 49 ans sébastien chenu c'est coloré en
bleu marine il y a huit ans seulement
avant il a été chef adjoint de cabinet
de christine lagarde en 2005
puis conseiller en communication auprès
des ministres durant quatre ans sous
nicolas sarkozy
est ce que vous voyez de demain c'est
marine encore fait ils ne peuvent pas
exactement ce qu'elle veut de moi elle
sait que je suis à ses côtés pour servir
notre pays nos idées elle même
quand certains ont rejoint les sirènes
et maurienne sébastien chenu a su rester
fidèle tout comme david rachline très
proche de marine le pen maire de fréjus
une des 14 villes gérées par le rn lui
imaginerait bien sébastien chenu rue de
valois
des hypothèses bientôt obsolète deux
jours plus tard marine le pen atteindra
moins de
41,5 pour cent des voix 5 million et
demi de moins qu emmanuel macron
[Applaudissements]
un président qui pour son dernier
déplacement de campagne choisi
l'occitanie
la regarde pas
la région de la députée verdi jouclas à
deux heures et demie de voiture tout de
même
bien occitanie bien à la réalité bien
chez ma collègue huguette genia qui a
fait un super boulot pendant cinq ans et
est donc je suis très très contente que
ça se passe là bas
figeac est une petite ville industrielle
et socialistes en pleine campagne qui a
placé jean luc mélenchon deuxième
position derrière emmanuel macron
dans la foule d'autres députés du coin
comme mireille robert salut de laudun
j
ai par contre moi je suis équipé je suis
suivie dans tout ce qu'on dit
est la grande question du jour est la
suivante je ne sais pas on va pas
pouvoir le voir dès la prochaine ça va
être compliqué
la députée va même avoir quelques
surprises révélatrice de l'époque arnaud
viala président du conseil général de
l'aveyron étiqueter les républicains est
là aussi
[Musique]
non mais je veux dire
si la city
mais surtout
[Musique]
non mais bon
le premier ministre également de la
région et en fin de cdd est aussi venu
pour l'occasion
pas si sûr dans le petit centre ville de
figeac les places se mérite
non
l'europe et nos deux minutes
bientôt les longues minutes d'attentes
sont enfin récompensés pour
marie-christine verdier jouclas
[Applaudissements]
mais ce jour-là à figeac des militants
anti libéraux écologistes ne l'entendent
pas de cette façon
[Applaudissements]
deux jours plus tard emmanuel macron est
réélu président une première sous la
vème république hors cohabitation
mais avec
38,5 % des inscrits
ces cinq points de moins qu'en 2017
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
photo
j'ai gagné
des dents l'avant
et la mer
les bagarres sanglantes et les
entendez-vous
au pare balles